hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel about how to
survive in the online jungle do you know
what i dislike the most about digital
world
passwords you have to use them
absolutely everywhere to access anything
to order food from an italian restaurant
to check your email from a new computer
maybe to connect to wi-fi network or
even stream video from a smartphone to a
tv that's a lot of passwords and too
many for me
even fernando kubato who came up with
this method of authorization admitted
that over 40 years he had accumulated
about 100 different passwords personally
i have a ridiculous amount and it's
growing every single day furthermore
passwords are too insecure most users
have passwords that are too easy to
steal or guess or crack so why are we
still using them but more importantly do
we have any real alternatives
well today we're going to be taking a
look into the brave new world of
passwordless authorization
[Music]
the key ideas that form the basis of
this authorization method appeared a
long time before the invention of
computers the first passwords were
actually utilized by roman legionnaires
around 200 bc the code word was written
on a wooden tablet and sent to the
commander of one of the detachments
having memorized the word the commander
sent the tablet onto another squadron so
the whole legion learned the password as
it moved down the chain the commander of
the last attachment returned the tablet
to its source this meant that it did not
fall into the hands of the enemy the
password was the same for all soldiers
but it changed every evening and in
those days it was quite sufficient in
terms of security even if a spy managed
to figure out the password it was almost
impossible to pass it to the army as
quick as it needed to be passed on
[Music]
therefore this system was good enough to
prevent cunning ghouls from getting into
the camp now promo codes work on a very
similar principle if you know the magic
word you get a discount but this
approach is hardly suitable for security
the speed of information dissemination
is measured not in days but in seconds
the code word can very easily fall into
the wrong hands to solve the problem of
authentication programmers turned to the
experience of sailors before the advent
of modern equipment and gps they
calculated their speed using a log
they would throw the lock into the water
and measure how quickly it would trail
behind the ship now the result these
calculations were recorded in the ship's
log book
of course only officers could keep such
records as only they had access to the
log and thus the expression login
appeared meaning to add information now
in 1962 fernado covato combined the
concept of restricted access and a code
word it's it's a complicated question
about saving or using time
uh we actually
save quite a bit of time in the sense
that the person is able to
be more selective be more shrewd the mit
professor gave users unique names and
passwords in order to limit the time
they worked on the institute's computer
however in those days computer resources
were severely limited so kubato could
not afford to waste them on making some
kind of encryption all password data was
stored as an unprotected text file of
course in the same year there was a
student who took advantage of this alan
sher was not satisfied that he was only
supposed to have four sessions on the
computer per semester then he stumbled
upon the
uaccnt.secret file which turned out to
contain the credentials of all users
alan calmly printed out this file and
told a couple of friends about in the
process the hacking went completely
unnoticed it was only 25 years later
that sher shared this story the
capability of computers grew and the
number of suspicious security incidents
grew with it
share was one of the first ever hackers
but the number of hackers was rapidly on
the rise as early as the 70s unix
systems began storing hash functions
instead of passwords now i've already
described in detail what hash functions
are
especially in the video about
cryptocurrencies so i won't dwell on
this too much now if you're interested
you can actually find a link to that
video in the description at the end of
the last century it seemed that such an
approach provided reliable protection
hackers ultimately didn't have computers
at their disposal that could figure out
a password by its hash but then the
human factor came into play
[Music]
do you remember your first ever password
it doesn't matter what for it could have
been an email account a social network
or a workstation the main thing is that
you're thinking of the very first one
you had
well recently we found out that the
first passwords of outstanding
programmers were quite funny and in 2014
enthusiasts found a file with the hashes
of one of the first ever unix systems
then passwords were limited to only
eight characters and the simple crypt
three algorithm was used to create a
hash it took six whole days to sort
through but now we know that the first
password of dennis ritchie the creator
of the c language was the technical
abbreviation dmac
marshall mccoosick one of the founding
fathers of freebsd chose a slang word as
his password fubar
eric schmidt on the other hand a future
google executive used his wife's name
with three exclamation marks stephen
bourne the author of shell just used his
last name
born it was only with the password of
ken thompson the creator of unix that
the enthusiasts had to work a little
harder it transpired later that ken had
used a very strange combination
meaningless symbols well not quite these
are actually the options for recording
chess moves look this is what thompson's
password looks like on the board
just follow the move of the queen's pawn
opening now which of these examples do
you think your first password was most
like in 1988 robert morris carried out
the first attack on simple user
passwords he wrote a worm that tried to
log into user accounts by substituting
passwords from his database
now
there are only 400 words in this
database but look this list includes a
few popular sports some common names a
couple of superheroes nothing
particularly complicated just lowercase
letters without numbers and other
symbols and it's all very simple
nevertheless morris's program managed to
infiltrate 47 000 computers around the
world the network was paralyzed the
total damage amounted to around 98
million us dollars and as a result
morris received three years of probation
and became the first ever convicted
cyber criminal but why have i brought
this story up well more than 30 years
have passed did our passwords have only
become weaker if you analyze password
leaks over the past year you can easily
make a hit parade of the most popular
passwords in the first place we have
one two three four five six in 2021 more
than 100 million people used this
password but check out the rest
now if you remove only numerical
passwords from the list the situation
doesn't get much better at all check
this out
[Music]
according to google a quarter of
americans use passwords as simple as
these and another 59 refer to their real
name or date of birth in the password so
why is this happening well look we're
not computers and we don't like to
invent and then remember passwords
all of these rules at least eight
characters lowercase and uppercase
letters mandatory numbers and additional
characters well they all tire us out if
an online service asks you to create
such a cryptic password you'll most
likely just scoff and not complete the
registration at all but the guys in the
it companies understand this perfectly
well so they often deliberately soften
the password requirements complex
registration requirements reduce the
flow of customers and therefore many
startups are sacrificing network
security for sake of user convenience
you know we're all quite content on
typing our names in maybe on pets names
right or just pressing a certain
combination of numbers and keys and then
we're surprised when our accounts are
hacked later on down the line however
even a strong password is unlikely to
help here for example my favorite
password consists of 12 letters and
meets all of the formal requirements but
this is a pretty bad password why
well because you know it in fact i just
generated it on one of the many password
creation sites that are out there but
it's important to demonstrate that our
passwords are less protected from
espionage than roman wooden tablets in a
cafe or a library an attacker can simply
look over your shoulder and watch you
input your password a key logger can be
installed on your work computer and from
home you might follow a phishing link
accidentally and give your password to
the criminals yourself
but there are also data leaks from
hacked sites i mean the average user
today uses about 200 different accounts
and 66 of people are not afraid to use
the same password twice admit it have
you really come up with different
passwords for all of the services you
use probably not and i imagine the
password that you use for all not very
important services got into the hands of
attackers because of one site security
breach you can actually lose a dozen
different accounts some users will
actually use the same combination of
characters as the sort of password core
but then they'll add something else to
it like a kind of suffix right maybe a
different collection of numbers or say
an abbreviated name of the service so
something like qwerty can turn into
kwerty
or
insta right a good trick well not really
it's as obvious to scammers as it is to
you but understanding all of this and
acting upon it won't protect you from
another threat of the online jungle
online extortion
take a look at this letter which is
well modern take on the nigerian print
scam only a lot more harrowing you see
here the idea is to use real data to
lure
200 out of a person by proving in the
first line that they really know your
password the criminals here managed to
collect more than half a million dollars
in this wallet so i don't think they
spent more than a couple hundred on
buying information that forms the basis
of their scheme in the first place but
back to passwords carefully memorize a
random combination of characters that
use for only one account and do not
record or save it anywhere should be the
official advice right but it turns out
that in order to feel protected i need
to learn about 200 random passwords of a
dozen characters each and not get
confused about what's what
of course i'm a smart guy but i don't
have an identic memory so what can i do
here
[Music]
well a friend of mine boasted that he
had come up with the perfect solution to
this problem he memorized one complex
password for his mailbox and he doesn't
even try to remember all the others
every time he needs to log into some way
well he just uses the password recovery
function goes to his email resets the
password and well
he gets a new password every single time
he uses this new password once then
deletes the email from the mailbox he
repeats that again and again and again
all he has to do is remember one
password and it's all good now of course
it's time consuming but it's effective
the only drawback of this plan is that
the services might consider this kind of
activity suspicious and they'll block
the account i'll consider you don't know
any of your passwords to anything else
well that's a big problem in fact my
friend was doing what in web development
is called magic links one of the major
web services tumblr was the first to
actually implement this functionality
and they came up with this unique name
although in fact it's actually quite
simple to log into your account using a
link from an email right a more advanced
solution to the problem is having a
single point of login for example one
login for all of your google accounts
allows you to work with say your email
service file storage office programs you
could manage your youtube channel right
and also set up advertising campaigns
google has expanded the possibility to
use this account on other sites as well
in this case the data exchange process
takes place automatically the user only
needs to consent to it now the result
here is that it's much faster than
making a new profile from scratch every
single time google simply exchanges data
with the other sites using the oauth 2.0
protocol this protocol not only
identifies the user as a particular user
of google services but also makes it
possible to determine which rights are
available to said person the chain of
logic looks something like this
the user enters a password from the
identity provider in our case it's
google now they do this in order to
access another site for instance
booking.com
the site here acts as the service
provider you trust google
booking.com trusts google as well so now
you and booking.com can also trust each
other this allows the site not only to
recognize you but also to interact with
other google services for instance it
might automatically add information
about the hotels that you've booked to
your calendar now this is convenient but
it raises two issues firstly the service
that you use to log into other sites
will know a lot more about you this is
unlikely to suit people who are
seriously worried about network security
for instance and secondly the loss of a
password to a single entry point
threatens the loss of all associated
accounts in this case it's even more
crucial that you pay attention to the
safe use of passwords hence the most
common method of protecting important
passwords has become two-factor
authentication
[Music]
this method of protection is already
used by more than 37 of american users
if you like me post your videos on
youtube then you already know exactly
what this is
two-factor authentication is based on
the fact that it's simply not enough to
simply know the correct password to log
in you've also got to have some kind of
pre-arranged item to hand be it an email
address a mobile phone number right and
in fact your bank card works in the same
way
the pin code is the key that you know
and the card itself is the key that you
own right if you're an accountant or the
owner of a company you've probably
encountered security keys or tokens
before these are often confused with
ordinary flash drives but actually a
unique key is stored inside them which
cannot be copied and can be used as the
second factor of authentication now in
2017 google conducted an experiment on
its employees 85 000 people received a
ub key security key and for a year
hackers were unable to get access to any
of the protected accounts now unlike sim
cards they cannot be cloned and unlike a
mailbox they cannot be lured out by
phishing
the only drawback of these keys is the
price the most affordable ub key costs
about 25 us dollars i think this is one
of the factors preventing these tokens
from being widely used
the good news is that with such a key we
can completely abandon inconvenient
passwords
[Music]
look we already have keys in our hands
that are difficult to forge or steal
unnoticed so why bother with passwords
at all
many have thought about it but microsoft
managed to take the first big step
towards this idea in september 2021
windows users were able to delete
passwords 85 million people logged in
using windows hello or the microsoft
authenticator looks like a lot of people
are getting bored with passwords for
passwordless authentication we can use
one or a couple of factors from the
classic three let's weigh the advantages
and disadvantages of each option okay so
this can be a short pin or maybe an
answer to some secret questions
just please don't put questions such as
what is your mother's maiden name or the
name of your first pet right
you can also have things like quotes
from the user agreements and similar
things like this of the advantages it's
as simple as possible to implement the
disadvantages however are the extremely
low security finding out a pin or say
answers to some questions well it's
easier than stealing the password itself
next we've got possession factors now
this can be a mailbox for instance as in
the case of magic links maybe a mobile
phone a smart watch a bank card an fc
tag or a secure key the pros are that
most of this is very difficult to steal
unnoticed and the authorization via sms
or push notifications has already become
a very familiar process for many however
the cons well there is the need for an
additional device and there are some
problems if it breaks
then we've got inherent factors now
these factors include biometric and
behavioral factors right five to seven
years ago this required complex and
expensive devices but today fingerprint
scanners are in most smartphones and
cameras nowadays they're able to
actually recognize faces and also make
sure that no one is looking over your
shoulder at your screen at the same time
more exotic methods well there's voice
recognition or keyboard handwriting and
they're still waiting for their finest
hour the main advantage of biometrics is
that the key is always with you the
disadvantages however the complexity of
the equipment and also the fact that
fraud is still a possibility microsoft
found a pretty clever solution here
users themselves choose which
combination to use it could be
a pin
fido two security keys face and
fingerprint recognition
sms confirmations and and also via the
microsoft authentication app in march of
2022 this initiative was supported by
the entire fido alliance chip developers
creators of operating systems for
computers and smartphones major internet
platforms and banking organizations they
all said that they had never been so
close to creating a passwordless world
now i'd like to believe this but well
do you remember the google report
even the simplest security tool a
password manager is used by only 15
percent of users today but 36 percent
write down passwords on piece of paper
that they leave next to their computer
conveniently
do you think that they really use
different passwords of different
services i doubt it very much the
problem here is people don't value
privacy
[Music]
but anyway why do we still love
passwords so much well i think it's a
matter of habit the first passwords
appeared in the year when the beatles
released their first single
passwords are sure inconvenient but over
the last 60 years we've become more
accustomed to them moreover the
requirements have been increasing very
gradually right in a quite a comfortable
way before the rise of web 2.0 we
generally had a need for only about two
or three passwords we have adapted
evolved right maybe somebody collects
passwords in a file and uploads it to
the cloud maybe someone stores messages
in messages or in drafts of letters
in other instances stickers with
passwords are plastered over monitors
and sometimes they can even be seen in
it companies
i don't know which of these methods is
worse to be honest i mean they're all
extremely unsafe but common nevertheless
and we're also pretty afraid to give up
these crutches right now we've been
walking with them for so long we're
afraid of falling if we throw them aside
password technologies also tend to
inspire fear in those who are paranoid
about their online presence many believe
that biometric information from our
devices will go straight to the clutches
of the nsa the kgb i mean you can prove
for a long time and persistently that a
smartphone exchanges only cryptographic
keys with servers but it's really
useless people love conspiracy theories
andrew shikiar the executive director of
the fido alliance formulates the main
objective in these words
not using a password should be easier
than using a password
now on the one hand he's right the
misuse of passwords is a threat to our
overall security about 80 of data
leakage incidents are caused by weak or
compromised passwords reliable
authentication is the foundation of
digital trust and the key to
cybersecurity in the new economy on the
other hand i kind of hate that someone
decides how to ensure security without
being particularly interested in my
opinion or habits right
fernando corbato wrote down passwords on
pieces of paper for the rest of his life
and that didn't stop him from changing
our world for the better well anyway
this is bradley signing off and thank
you so much for joining us on another
jungle adventure i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
you